on parle beaucoup d'ailleurs on a parlé
tout à l'heure thomas de la droitisation
du débat public est globalement de tout
cadre tout neuf de toute la politique
non c'est pas un train je pense qu'il ya
un super papier qui est sorti
aujourd'hui dans esprit par vincent
tiberj je vous explique que c'est un peu
plus nuancé que ça
nous sur beaucoup de questions peu
pareil il a mis plein d'indicateurs est
dit on peut pas exactement conclure à
une droitisation c'est sur les deux
faces ont aussi aussi aussi lapidaire
ce que je voudrais dire c'est que la
droite lorsqu'on parle de droitisation
il ya une chose qui est certaine c'est
que c'est le souhait de beaucoup
d'acteurs politiques de beaucoup
d'acteurs médiatique de droitiser le
débat est d'utiliser les thèmes dont
vous avez parlé frédéric c'est-à-dire
l'immigration le la question de la
sécurité est d'en parler sans cesse moi
j'ai un exemple parce que je trouve que
ça a été une parenthèse un peu enchantée
est vraiment bienvenu dans le pendant
pendant pendant au moins quelques
semaines c'était la primaire de dévers
des écolos pendant la primaire des
écolos ils ont parlé d'autres sujets
pendant quelques semaines et bien sûr
les différentes chaînes d'information
continue dans les médias on a parlé
d'autre chose en fait que sans arrêt les
peines qui était mise en avant par eric
zemmour avec des propositions qui était
tout à fait intéressante entre delphine
batho sandrine rousseau et yannick jadot
eric piolle ils avaient tous des
propositions différentes affaires dont
on a parlé d'autre chose ce qui veut
dire que dans ceux dans ce moment là ça
a bien démontré que les acteurs
politiques étaient maîtres en fait de
leur agenda médiatique et de ceux dont
il avait envie de parler de moi j'invite
les différents protagonistes n'a delà de
la présidentielle à se ressaisir en fait
des sujets dont ils veulent parler et
ils ont il paraît pouvoir d'achat qu'ils
parlent de pouvoir d'achat et qu'ils
arrêtent en fait de se faire
systématiquement emmené nomme par les
médias dominants sur des sujets dont le
plus souvent d'abord ils vont raconter
n'importe quoi ce que j'en sois et sujet
notamment de sécurité le plus souvent
c'est une espèce de surenchère policière
s'en va on n'en voit plus le bout et on
l'a bien vu pendant la primaire delà de
la notamment et à se ressaisir en fait
des sujets qui sont les leurs même
d'avery pécresse au bout d'un moment il
va falloir que valérie pécresse elle
trouve en fait les sujets pour se
recréer une colonne vertébrale
idéologique qui tienne la route et qui
est qu'elle nous explique en quoi est
différente des manuels macron et d'eric
zemmour parce qu'aujourd'hui ou bien
elle va aller chercher un peu du côté
des débats n'est mâcon ou bien aller
chercher un peu du côté d'eric zemmour
sur les questions d'immigration et de
sécurité mais on n'arrive pas comme
falloir qu'elle récupère en fait son
agenda politique pour pouvoir produire
un discours qui tienne la route et il
faut que ça soit le cas pour tous les
autres candidats
[Musique]